hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen it's Halloween if you
haven't noticed and you know I have a
love-hate relationship with those
itty-bitty Halloween candy bars you in
theory they're portion control right 60
calories two bites of chocolatey
goodness no big deal but when you're
sitting down with a bowl of these
waiting for that half-naked six-year-old
dressed up as Miley Cyrus to show up at
your door it can be really easy to plow
through 10 30 40 of these let's be
honest we've all found ourselves
secretly sifting through our kids
Halloween bins unwrapping one baby bar
after the other until we feel sicker
than had we just spent an hour watching
the Kardashians Oh
sounds more like a trick than a treat to
me so I came up with my top 5 tips to
help you get through Halloween without
the - candy bar binges one eye candy you
don't love if you're a chocolate peanut
go with chips if you're a salty holic
buy candy personally I think tootsie
rolls tastes like chocolate flavored
chalks hey that's usually a pretty safe
bet for me tip to chew sugar-free gum
you can't chew gum and each up at the
same time
well not gracefully anyway chewing gum
is a great way to keep your mouth busy
your breath fresh and satisfy that sweet
tooth if you find your hand reaching
into the candy bowl for the third time
tip 3 kick off the festivities with a
satisfying meal Halloween is a celebrity
night so treat yourself to a flavorful
fulfilling meal a combination of fiber
protein and healthy fats will keep those
cravings at bay while a festive menu
will ensure you never feel deprived -
check out my video here for some
Halloween party inspiration tip 4 get up
to answer the door don't just sit there
at the door with your hand in the candy
been waiting for Princess Elsa and
Ironman show up put down the sweets get
up walk around do some errands you
some emails and then walk back everytime
you hear that doorbell ring exercise +
distraction a winning combination every
time and finally tip 5 allow yourself a
mindful treat mindful eating doesn't
mean depriving yourself of a pleasurable
indulgence so while you may want to
avoid buying your all-time favorite
trick or treats and then attempt to
stave off those sugar shakes you know
promise yourself something sweet that
you'll truly enjoy so whether it's a
whole new dessert a piece of candy from
your kids stash always ask permission
first or a shot straight up vodka
hey I'm judge the key here is to always
make sure you never let yourself get to
diet deprival mode here's to finding
some fun this Halloween is something a
little more exciting than a stale bag of
cheese puffs thanks so much for watching
guys happy Halloween
for more guilt-free holiday ideas and be
sure to subscribe to my channel and I'll
see you next time on Abbey's kitchen
you